imagine a world in which woolly mammoths
roam the plains of siberia
where dodos flock on the shores of
mauritius
or where 12-foot tall saber-toothed cats
stroll through the woods of north
america
well maybe no thanks to that last one
but a world in which extinct animals are
brought back to life
may not be limited to the imagination
for much longer
de-extinction is the process of bringing
back to life
an extinct animal species it's an idea
that's been around for a while
but was perhaps fully propelled into the
public consciousness by the 1993 film
jurassic park
while resurrected dinosaurs remain
firmly in the realms of science fiction
the de-extinction of other animals is a
much closer horizon
we are currently living through earth's
sixth mass extinction period
called the holocene extinction this mass
extinction
closely correlates to human activity
through hunting deforestation
pollution climate change and other side
effects of human expansion
we may have lost close to seven percent
of all species on the planet
but de-extinction could be one way of
resurrecting lost
species and protecting those most at
risk today
and with recent developments in genome
sequencing
genetic engineering and cloning
scientists have now begun to resurrect
recently extinct species
and have their sights set on those lost
further back in time
so is a jurassic park style zoo filled
with extinct species
actually possible what would we need to
do to bring back
animals that would otherwise be lost
forever
[Music]
to fill our hypothetical zoo one of the
first decisions would be which
animals to bring back to life this would
depend on our goal
and there are a number of reasons why we
might want to de-extinct a range of
different species
one big motivation for de-extinction is
to increase biodiversity
having a variety of animals plants and
insects in an ecosystem is important
as all of these different creatures
perform different vital roles
predators like wolves and bears keep
populations of smaller mammals in check
beavers build dams that slow down rivers
to create safe environments
for other water-loving animals and
pollinators like bees and wasps help
plants reproduce
if one animal dies out it can cause
knock-on effects that destabilize the
entire ecosystem
de-extincting animals that are essential
to managing and maintaining their
original ecosystems
could help return those ecosystems back
to health
another reason we might want to bring
back lost species is to learn from them
many of the medicines and technological
innovations we use today
have been developed from initial
discoveries in nature
extinct species may hold answers to some
of our most puzzling research questions
and de-extinction techniques can also be
used in the race to save endangered
species we may not be able to bring back
every lost animal but we might be able
to boost populations that are at risk of
disappearing now
and there may be a moral obligation to
bring back
animals that humans are responsible for
eradicating
the extinction rate now is thought to be
a thousand times faster than before
humans became the planet's dominant
species
and a quarter of all mammals now are at
risk of extinction
we've got a lot to make up for however
there are
limitations it won't be possible to
bring back every extinct species
with current technology that relies
heavily on dna and well-preserved tissue
it's unlikely we'll be able to
de-extinct anything that died out more
than 10
000 years ago because dna doesn't last
that long
when an organism dies cells break down
exposing dna in the nucleus to damage by
enzymes and microorganisms
this means that in really old tissue dna
is either non-existent
or only present in tiny amounts so
for better or worse that rules out the
dinosaurs
it's also much harder to de-extinct
birds or reptiles compared to mammals
because we know so much more about
mammalian reproduction compared to birds
and reptiles
but if we had a mammal in mind which
lived within the last few thousand years
how would we go about bringing them back
there are three main routes
currently being explored in the push to
de-extinct animals
and they all have pros and cons
we had lots of time and a few acres of
land we could try
back breeding back breeding is a process
where lost traits are bred back into
living species
sort of converting an existing species
back into a previous form
to understand this method let's look at
an attempt by researchers in south
africa to recreate the quagga
an extinct subspecies of zebra quagas
and zebras are pretty similar
but where zebras are covered in stripes
quaggas only have stripes on the front
half of their bodies
quaggas also have brown coloring on
their rear
quaggas were common in south africa
until european settlers hunted them into
extinction in the late 19th century
because zebras are a closely related
species to the extinct quagga
they are the starting point of the study
to begin recreating the quagga
scientists select individual zebras that
express the same
or very similar traits to the extinct
species
such as zebras with fewer stripes on the
back half of their bodies
or zebras with more brown coloring on
their back half
then once these individual animals have
been identified
they are bred together any offspring
that have inherited the desired traits
will be bred again
hopefully producing a new generation
that carry a mix of extinct species
traits
this process needs to be repeated until
the resulting animal is as close to the
extinct species as possible
the back breeding project started over
30 years ago
and in that time has produced multiple
breeding groups of
nearly quaggas after several generations
of the selective breeding
the animals aren't quite the same as the
originals
but they do have the half stripes and
brown rears of their extinct relatives
but there are some downsides and
challenges to back breeding that mean it
might not be a suitable approach for
every animal
first of all we'd need a really close
relative of the extinct species to act
as our starting point
for animals extinct many thousands of
years ago this may not be possible
it's also a really long process the
gestation period for a zebra for example
is 12 months if we need to repeat the
breeding process several times over it
could be years
or even decades before a herd of our
extinct species is ready
and it's an imprecise process although
genome sequencing and in vitro
fertilization can help
breeders be more selective about what
gets passed on
you can't guarantee the traits you
expect to see in the new generation will
materialize
but luckily even if we don't have a
starter species or we don't have time to
breed multiple generations
there are some other options
another route to de-extinction is
cloning clones are
exact genetic replicas of another
organism and arise all the time
in nature bacteria clone themselves as a
means of reproduction
and identical twins are technically
clones of each other
but cloning can also be done in the lab
we've cloned lots of animals
including buffalo dogs and camels so how
could we use cloning to bring back
a long dead species the most reliable
method
is probably scnt somatic cell nuclear
transfer
this is the method pioneered by the
creators of dolly the sheep
the first cloned mammal and surprisingly
scientists have already attempted this
method it began in 1999
when researchers captured the last
surviving pyrenean ibex
a female named celia they obtained skin
biopsies and froze the tissue in liquid
nitrogen
then in 2009 those skin cells were used
to clone celia
in the first ever case of actual
de-extinction
first the nuclei from the frozen skin
cells were removed
and injected into donor eggs taken from
domestic goats
which had their own nuclei removed by
adding some chemicals and a jolt of
electricity
the process of embryonic development was
started after a few days of growth in
the lab
the embryos were implanted into a
surrogate mother
either a spanish ibex or an ibex goat
hybrid
the resulting fetuses had exactly the
same dna as the extinct
animal of the 208 embryos the
researchers implanted
only seven pregnancies resulted and just
one ibex made it to term
this was a huge accomplishment the first
ever extinct animal brought back
into existence however the baby ibex
died
almost immediately from respiratory
failure most embryos derived from clones
don't develop
properly and we don't fully know why
research suggests that it's not just one
stage of the cloning process that is
causing damage to the resulting embryos
but in fact many if not all stages
contribute
from the act of moving the nucleus from
one cell to another
to the use of chemicals to kickstart
embryonic development
but scientists are not ready to give up
so quickly
instead setting their sights on an even
loftier goal
de-extincting one of the greatest
megafauna of all time
the woolly mammoth in 2019
a major breakthrough in the effort to
bring back this incredible
animal occurred when a team in japan
successfully transferred the nucleus
from a frozen mammoth cell
into the egg of a mouse the nucleus came
from a 28 000 year old preserved mammoth
named yuka
the goal of the experiment was not to
create some kind of mammoth mouse hybrid
it was to see if this ancient dna had
the potential to be re-awakened
could the cellular machinery in a mouse
egg fix the damaged parts of the mammoth
dna
and kick-start the dna replication
necessary for embryonic development
if it could that would suggest there is
potential for harvested preserved
mammoth dna
to be brought back to life through
cloning and the mouse cell machinery
did manage to fix some parts of the
damaged dna
and there were some very early signs of
the mechanics that underpin
dna replication but ultimately the mouse
egg could only do so much
the mammoth dna was too badly damaged
and so it's nearly impossible to
reconstitute it enough to actually bring
it back to life
for now cloning a mammoth is still a
far-off dream
but research like this adds to the field
of knowledge that might get us there one
day
but there is one other approach we could
try and it has elements of back breeding
and cloning a new technology opening up
options for de-extinction is genetic
engineering
more specifically crispr technology
crispr cast 9 is a type of molecular
scissor that can cut dna
at a pre-programmed position this means
strands of dna can be added removed or
edited at specific points in the dna
we could insert genes from an extinct
animal into the dna of a close relative
creating a hybrid with the phenotype the
physical attributes of the extinct
species
to do this we'd first need to sequence
the extinct animal genome
if we have preserved dna for example
from mammoth tissue in the permafrost
we can use genome sequencing to work out
its entire genetic
code and use tests to work out which
genes are linked to the phenotype of the
extinct
species if we then compare the extinct
species genetic code to that of its
closest
living relative we could work out where
they differ
finally we could copy and paste the
genes we want from the existing animal
into the host animal dna
researchers at harvard university are
trying to use this crispr technology to
splice
mammoth genes into asian elephant dna
but it's a monumental task there are
around 1.4 million known gene mutations
separating mammoths and asian elephants
and not all of the mutations will relate
to the mammoth phenotype
it will take a long while yet to work
out which mammoth genes need to be
swapped into elephant dna
to recreate a woolly mammoth but the
idea may be the most promising yet
and one day we may just see the first
baby mammoth to live
in 10 000 years
[Music]
although none of these methods are
perfect they are certainly bringing us
closer to the de-extinction of lost
species and to protecting and reviving
endangered animal populations but before
we get too
excited about bringing back everything
from mammoths to thylacines to dodos
we might want to pause and decide
whether we should bring back any lost
species
at all because as cool as it might be to
create a de-extinction safari park
there are some risks while reintroducing
recently extinct species
might prove beneficial to existing
ecosystems
long dead species could end up doing
more harm
than good because of the changes those
ecosystems have
undergone in the intervening period it
could create similar problems to those
we've seen
when releasing non-native species into
new areas
when the poisonous cane toad was
introduced to australia to control the
grey-backed cane beetle
the toad quickly spread and pushed out
native toad populations
an extinct species might out-compete one
that has developed in its absence
or the ecosystems that once supported an
extinct species might no longer be a
suitable home
the chinese river dolphin was polluted
out of the yangtze river
and things haven't improved since they
wouldn't survive there today
if and when we are able to successfully
and reliably bring back
lost species particularly those that
have been extinct for thousands of years
we will need to think carefully about
whether these are risks
we want to take but every day between 30
and 150 species of animal die out on
earth for good
alongside conservation efforts
de-extinction
could be a potential avenue to undo some
of the damage that humans have enacted
on the planet one of the most mysterious
and strange
animals to ever live on our planet was
the thylacine
found in australia tasmania and new
guinea
it was the largest carnivorous marsupial
with a body that looks like a cross
between a cat
and a dog also known as the tasmanian
tiger
it was wiped from the continent of
australia 3
000 years ago and survived in tasmania
until the 1930s
when humans finally hunted it into
extinction
over recent years there have been many
reports of thylacine sightings in the
jungles of tasmania
giving some hope that a few individuals
remain
but these sightings are almost all
exaggerated or are cases of mistaken
identity
sadly the thylacine is still very much
extinct
but it may not be forever geneticists
are working to resurrect this enigmatic
animal
with crispr and cloning working with a
tiny relative of the thylacine
a numbat to see how scientists are
working to understand these marsupial
genetics
and to see how close they are to making
a living thylacine a reality
you should watch resurrecting tasmanian
tigers on curiosity stream
curiosity stream is a streaming platform
with thousands of high quality
documentaries like this one
and now curiositystream has partnered
with us to offer
an incredible deal by signing up to
curiositystream you now
also get a subscription to nebula nebula
is a streaming platform made by me
and several other educational youtube
content creators
it's a place where we can upload our
videos and podcasts
free and a place where we can experiment
with new original content
by signing up to the bundle deal you'll
get access to both curiosity stream
and nebula our newest project is modulus
a podcast where we talk to the people
behind the science we explore here on
youtube
the latest episode uncovers the mystery
of a haunting sound produced by sand
dunes
at only a handful of sites around the
world it's a sound that made
explorers like marco polo think he was
surrounded by evil
desert spirits it's a mystery that went
unsolved for centuries
you can learn how scientists finally
figured it out by listening to modulus
ad-free on nebula
so by signing up at curiositystream
real science you'll get a subscription
to curiosity stream
and a subscription to nebula for just
14.79 for the entire year
signing up is also the best way to
support this channel and
all of your favorite educational content
creators
thanks for watching and if you'd like to
see more from me the links to my
instagram
twitter and patreon are below
you